meine damen und herren ich spreche heute
zum thema liebe und recht viel theorie
in einer feministischen perspektive
auf die geschichte der philosophie
erweist sich die paradigmatische
bedeutung von fichte sail ihre für die
begründung der bürgerlichen
geschlechterordnung
der durch muss so eröffnete
sentimentaler gut naturphilosoph rische
differenz diskurs wird mit dem durch das
neuzeitliche naturrecht begründeten
egalität prinzip so zusammengeführt dass
die er zugleich als eine der natur
verdammte liebes gemeinschaft und als
form sittlicher vergemeinschaftung von
individuen bestimmt wird die jedoch nur
als in klagerechts freiheit gedacht
werden kann
diese konzeption fließt in das
selbstverständnis der individuen ebenso
wie in die bürgerlichen gesetzbuch
bücher ein und bleibt bis zur mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhundert so kann man
glaube ich sagen prägend in der
systematik von fichtes philosophie
hingegen kommt dieser gemeinschaft sowie
generell eine doppelte bedeutung zu
einerseits realisiert sich in ihr jene
transformationen der natur in von und
deren herr ballführung durch kultur die
bestimmung des menschen ist so gesehen
ist die ihr selbstzweck sie ist aber
auch wesentlich lux mitte zu diesem
menschheit lich zu realisierenden zweck
der seinerseits die sittliche einheit
der menschheit ermöglicht das mag als
orientierung
äußert sich zum motiv der befassung mit
diesen gegenständen folgt zitat
es ist mir ein gedanke gekommen von
welch wirklich aber nicht weiß ob ich
moser habe werde diesen sommer
auszuführen und den ich ihnen auf jeden
fall im engsten vertrauen mitteile wir
sie denn wirklich der einige sind gegen
den ich im äußeren ein gewisses
aufstreben der weiber eine
unzufriedenheit derselbe mit ihrer
politischen lage gehört unter die
eigenheiten unseres zeitalters
dieser hang ist von schriftstellern
schon benutzt worden die einen haben ihn
günstig über die bürgerliche
verbesserung der weiber zum beispiel die
anderen jeder gedrückt getadelt
passiviert an einer gründlichen
untersuchung fehlt ich glaube es wäre
darüber etwa im tone eines gewissen
beitrags ein höchst interessantes buch
zu schreiben
zitat ende
dieser brief von 17 95 an den verleger
quartal beweist dass sich die politisch
mit gleichheits bestrebungen von frauen
violette busch gefolge der französischen
revolution beobachtete und sich in die
um die besonders durch groß so entfachte
äußerst kontrovers geführte debatte um
die richtige ordnung der geschlechter
mit einem eigenen philosophisch beitrag
einbringen wollte leider als dieses
projekt nicht realisiert worden aber
immerhin hat fichte seine in
auseinandersetzungen mit den
zeitgenossen entwickelte position in dem
jenaer schriften und lage des
naturrechts und systemen der sittenlehre
in grundzügen dargestellt im mittelpunkt
der folgenden ausführungen steht die
geschlechter theologie in der grundlage
des naturrechts von 17 96
erinnern wird kurz an grundzüge der
schichten rechtsphilosophie
der grundbegriff des rechts muss in
vechta systemen durch reduktion aus dem
prinzip dass ich gewonnen werden das
heißt es ist zu erweisen dass der
begriff des rechts notwendige bedingung
des selbstbewusstseins ist um den gang
der detektion wenigstens ansatzweise
nachzuvollziehen
muss ja folgen des kunden dass ich denkt
sich notwendig als wollen das heißt als
freie selbstbestimmung zur wirksamkeit
wenn das ich sich aber zugleich
notwendig immer schon als durch objekte
bestimmtes wert scheint es unmöglich zu
sein sich als ursprünglicher selbst
anfang erfassen zu können
fichtes originelle die philosophie der
inter subjektivität gebäude lösung des
problems liegt bekanntlich um gedanken
der aufforderung wenn du das bestimmende
objekt nichts anderes ist als anders ich
ergebende aufforderung zur freien
selbstbestimmung kann das ich als in der
zeit durch ein objekt bestimmtes sich im
haus des ursprünglichen selbst anfangs
zu erfahrung bringen bedingung der
möglichkeit dieser aufforderung ist die
wechselseitige anerkennung der subjekte
als von und felsen und das heißt
natürlich als zwecke setzen gewesen
in der rechtsphilosophie wird klar dass
der mensch nicht nur individuum sondern
notwendigerweise gattungsgrenzen ist ich
zitiere der mensch wird nur unter
menschen ein mensch sollen überhaupt
menschen seien so müssen mehr darauf ein
der begriff des menschen ist so nach gar
nicht begriff eines einzelnen denn ein
solcher ist undenkbar sondern der
annagasse zitat ende
aus der tatsache dass
internationalität verstanden als
wechselseitige gewährung von und
erziehung zur freiheit notwendige
bedingung eines fans gegen wesens ist
leitet versteht das verhältnis ab zitat
ich musste es frei gewesen außer mir in
allen fällen anerkennen als ein solches
das heißt meine freiheit durch den
begriff der möglichkeit seiner freiheit
beschränken zitat ende
damit ist eine wesentliche forderung des
rechts erfüllt nämlich der gegenseitige
verzicht auf diejenigen handlung die die
freiheit des anderen beeinträchtigen
anders als für kant enthält der gedanke
des rechts verzichte kein kategorisches
sollen seine eigene freiheits fähre zu
beschränken ist nur hypothetisch
gefordert unter der bedingungen nämlich
dass der andere die seinige einschränkt
die geltung des rechts ergibt sich für
fichte also nicht aus rein praktischen
vernunft gesetzen sondern lediglich
zitat durch den willkürlichen entschluss
eines jeden mit anderen in gesellschaft
zu geben zitat ende
das gericht ist nun mit dem elternrecht
bestandteil des familienrechts das
fünfzigste neben dem völkerrecht im
anhang zur grundlage des naturrechts
abgehandelt wird
entscheidend für die stellung des
eherechts im ganzen der wichtigsten
rechtsphilosophie ist das die bisher
geleistete die diktion der gemeinschaft
vernünftiger in der st ingbert wirkende
wiesen in diesem fall keine zureichenden
basis für die anwendung des rechts
begriffs darstellt es bedarf eines
weiteren deducto schritt nämlich der
diktion der ihr
selbstzitat um den rechtsbegriff darauf
mit verstand einsetzen zu können
zitat ende
durch diese reduktion wird erst das
gericht als jene besondere rechts
abgerundet in der das verhältnis decken
die figuren zueinander gerade nicht im
sinne der sicherung ihrer freiheit
fairen gegeneinander durch vertrag zu
regeln
und durch den staat zu sichern ist im
gegenteil dient das ihr recht glücklich
und dem schutz einer zitat vollkommenen
vereinigung zitat von mann und frau die
als zitat natürliche und moralische
gesellschaft zitat nur durch die
preisgabe von rechten eines individuums
gegen das andere möglich wird
dies half ihr dieses anhangs handelt
fichte von der er als natürlicher also
vor rechtlicher gemeinschaft und in den
paragrafen 5 bis 9 geht es wohl eher als
moralischer also über rechtliche
gemeinschaft
ausgangspunkt für die reduktion der er
ist eine teleologische betrachtung zweck
der organischer natur zu der zu der der
mensch als leib wesen gehört ist die
fortpflanzung
mittel zur erreichung dieses zwecks ist
ein naturtrüb der in zwei abgesonderten
geschlechtern erscheint für den menschen
ist lediglich die beschädigung diese
streeps zweck durch ihren folgen der
natur zweck der fortpflanzung ohne zutun
des menschen realisiert wird
entscheidend für die probleme stellung
der ehe längere ist ca die besondere
bestimmungen dieser natur einrichtung
das bei der befriedigung des triebes zu
oder beförderung des natur zwecks was
den eigentlichen erzeugung anbelangt
dass ein geschlecht sich nur tätig dass
andere sich nur leidend verhalten zitat
ende ich lasse hier die begründung für
diese gemäß den seit aristoteles
bekannten
geschlechterstereotypen des passiven
weiblichen und aktiven männlichen
formulierte
fortpflanzungstrieb
der als reine passivität empfänglichkeit
gedacht der stoff wird auch bei fichte
auf der basis einer von aristoteles
vollkommen abweichenden ontologie im
vergleich zur aktivität der form als
minderwertig beurteilt und als der
spezifische beitrag der frau zur
kreation - angesetzt ein pflichttermin
terminologie ist der stoff zitat bloßes
objekt einer kraft werden holt die
natürlichen bestimmung der geschlechter
auf die vernunft natur des menschen
bezogen ergibt sich eine eklatante
differenz zwischen mann und frau stimme
die natur seite des männlichen
geschlechts als selbstständiges selbst
tätiges prinzip mit der vernunft natur
des menschen vollkommen überein so steht
die passivität der weiblichen natur in
strikter widerspruch zur vernunft
das setzen von zwecken ausdruck von
freiheit und mittel der realisierung von
freiheit in der sin welt ist gibt der
zweck der
karton gibt der zweck zu leiden von uns
gänzlich auf wolfs gesetzt ist dabei
dass sich die als zweck der natur
anzusehende passivität des weiblichen
geschlechts im unwillentlich erzeugungs
geschehen ohne weiteres auf die durch
die individuen selbst bezweckte art der
befriedigung jesus triebs überträgt
daraus erwächst der den weiblichen
menschen und nur dies nur kennzeichnende
fundamentale widerspruch zwischen natur
und verlust er besteht genau darum darin
dass die frauen setzen eines zwecks sich
formal als vernunft wesen beweist und im
selben takt sich durch die materie
dieses sex zum objekt der kraft eines
anderen machen ihre vernunft natur
auflebt
genau dieser die frau bestimmte
fundamentale konflikt macht es notwendig
die ihr als eine gesellschaftsform smit
generis zu begründen wäre die frau im
zeugungsakt aktiv wie der mann bedurfte
es keiner die optionen der ene sie wäre
ohne weiteres als vertragsgemeinschaft
zu fassen weil die frau aber durchgang
natur in rain vernunft natur nie sagt
scheider scheidet sie von vorne an als
gleichwertiger vertragspartner des
mannes aus es entsteht daher das problem
wie eine gemeinschaft von menschen zu
begründen ist die selbst durch
widersprüchliche reaktionen definiert
werden muss nämlich einerseits durch ein
der natur geschuldetes so koordinations
verhältnis die frau ist okay wenn nicht
ab kraft und andererseits durch ein der
vernunft verdammtes verhältnis der
gleichheit in moralischer hinsicht
die erstaunliche lösung fichtes besteht
kreisverband gesagt darin die beziehung
von mann und frau im binnenverhältnis
der als rechts frei zu denken
an die stille rechtlich geregelten
beziehung tritt ein verhältnis der liebe
des in der geschlechtlichen liebe der
frau seinen anfang nimmt zitat das war
kein bach aufsicht team umgebung der
geschlechts lust um ihren eigenen
betrieb zu befriedigen und da ist denn
doch zufolge als triebes sich hingeben
muss kann in dieser trieb kein anderer
sein als der den man zu befriedigen
zitat ende eine solche altruistisch
konnotierte unterwürfigkeit oder
selbstaufgabe
verspricht die bewahrung der eigenen
vernunft natur der frau
zitat sie behauptet ihre blöden
erachtet sie mittel wird dadurch dass
sie sich frei würden zufolge eines edlen
natur triebes dass der liebe zum mittel
macht
zitat ende
auf diese weise über die biologische
passivität der frau zur hingabe an einem
anderen sublimiert und zugleich
moralisiert dass ich auch die hebung der
frauen zu mitgemacht ist nach richtet
deshalb kein problem weil anders als auf
der stufe des betriebes die passivität
nicht selbst der angestrebte zweck ist
und der verfolgte zweck befriedigung des
mannes ihm als vernünftig geht in der
sich die frage ob diesem zweck zu eigen
macht wird ihre ruhe natur zugleich
moralisch
veredelt und somit verlor gemäss
lieber als sich opfern der frau ist
jedoch keine moralische tagte frau sie
opfert sich nicht zu folge eines
begriffs vom sittlich gute sollen
zufolge eines natur trieb dies nun hat
für das für sich seien der frau
entscheidende konsequenzen
projekt sie dem edlen naturtrüb wirkt
sie nicht nur mittel für den zweck des
mannes ihr eigener zweck besteht nicht
länger in der realisierung ihrer
freiheit durch vernunft sondern in der
befriedigung der bedürfnisse des herzens
zu lieben und ihrerseits bienen zu
werden die frau kann sich nach
geschichte den geschlechtstrieb in
seiner wahren gestalt nicht gestiegen
für sie erscheint er notwendig in
gestalt der liebe und das heißt das
bewusstsein der frau ist ein gefühl wenn
auch ein vernünftiges
diese überlegungen sind der ursprung für
die behauptung eines irakischen
anthropologischen unterschied der
geschlechter in ihrer geistigen
verfassung
darauf kommen wir später kurz zurück
systematisch entscheidung verpflichtet
ihre lehre ist aber der gedanke dass die
natur selbst in form der frau regelungen
des weiblichen geschlechts triebs zum
trieb der liebe nicht und nicht das
selbstbewusste handeln der frau eine
zweck hervorbringen kann der mit
moralität und vernunft kompatibel ist
und damit den lebendigen widerspruch in
der frau versöhnen kann
jeder ist so sicht der nächste
vereinigungs punkt der natur und der
vernunft sie ist das einzige
geht wo die natur immer die vernunft
eingang sie ist so nach das trefflichste
unter allen natürlichen zitat ende
mit den bisher geleisteten begründung
schritten ist erst der anfang zu
reduktion der ihr gemacht sie verändert
sich mit der aus den natürlichen
gegebenheiten zu entwickelnden
darstellung der ihr als moralischer
gemeinschaft von mann und frau die im
paragrafen beginnt das resultat der
gesamten reduktionen falls geschichte
muss statt philosophischen griff
aufnehmen in folgender definition
zusammen die er ist eine durch den
geschlechtstrieb gegründete
vollkommen vereinigung zweier personen
beiderlei geschlechts die ihr eigenes
zweck ist zitat ende um nun die elemente
dieser definition verstehen zu können
ist zunächst zu klären warum die
natürliche liebe noch keine zureichende
lösung für das aufgestellte problem dem
widerspruch zwischen natur und vernunft
in der frau zu beheben darstellen kann
dadurch dass die frau sich zu
mittelmacht wird zwar
widerspruch einerseits aufgehoben aber
gleichwohl bleibt die frau mitte oder
sie folgt als liebende einem naturtrüb
wenn auch einem veredelten
das heißt aber dass die frau so handeln
noch keineswegs in vollem umfang ihrer
vernunft natur entspricht
erst wenn das natürliche gefühl der
liebe auf ein individuum gezogen und als
solches für ewig wird in dem sich die
frau einem mann für immerhin gibt
behauptet sie ihm nachsichtige in
sämtlichen charakter das heißt ihre
wurde als fern und lesen
in der sittenlehre heißt es dazu zitat
könnte sie sich aber in der stunde der
ergebung zu irgendeiner zeit anders
denken denn als die seinige so findet
sie sich nicht gedrungen welche
voraussetzungen widerspricht und die
sittlichkeit aufgibt zitat ende
das heißt nur so ist der akte hingabe
als eine notwendige handlung
qualifiziert die anspruch auf
sittlichkeit beheben kann
ohne diese voraussetzung bliebe die
ergebung zufällig wäre also nicht durch
verlust begründet
unter der bedingung schrankenloser
hingabe aber er gibt sich harmonie von
vernunft und natur im positiven sinne
eine vollkommene vereinigung von mann
und frau ist in einem rechtlichen
verhältnis der anerkennung unmöglich
auch wenn es paradox erscheint dass
gerade die selbstbehauptung der frau als
vernunft wesen die konsequente abtretung
ihrer persönlichkeit als inbegriff aller
rechte an den geliebten 1 impliziert
dies ist die conditio sine qua non
vollkommener vereinigung denn so die
begründung
behielte die frau dem mann ja etwas vor
so würde sie eben dieses höher schätzen
als das hingegeben
nun gebe sie aber quali biete sich als
person also würde sie sich durch jeden
vorbehalt selbst als person eher niedrig
zitat ihrer eigenen würden gut daran
dass sie ganz so wie sie liebt und ist
ihres mannes sei und sich ohne vorbehalt
an ihn und im verloren habe das
geringste was daraus folgt ist dass sie
ihr vermögen und alle ihre rechte
abtreten und mit umziehen sie hat
aufgehört das leben eines individuums zu
führen ihr leben ist teil seines lebens
geworden
zitat ende
also nur durch die konstante und
konsequente hingabe allein man kann die
frau natur und sittlichkeit in
übereinstimmung bringen
ihre entrichtung ist daher sicherlich
geforderte zweck und nicht repression
von außen
begriff des rechts kein kategorisches
säulen keine pflicht gefasst ist ergibt
sich ein geschicktes system daraus kein
widerspruch
die preisgabe der rechtlichen
subjektivität wird positiv als
voraussetzung für ein durch zärtlichkeit
bestimmtes verhältnis der ergriffen
gedacht die frau verzichtet zwar auf
eine durch eigene zwecksetzung
bestimmtes wäre des handelns in dem sie
zur verwirklichung der zwecken des
mannes beiträgt sie gewinnt sich jedoch
in dieser hingabe zugleich als zwecke
verfolgen das wesen zurück sofern
nämlich eher durch rohes gut bestimmte
geliebte sich ihre zwecke zu eigen macht
sich deren realisierung angelegen sein
lässt dass sich verlegen sich finden im
anderen bedeutet zugleich selbst
verfolgt die frau stellt sich
moralischer hinsicht als ganzer mensch
wir in dem sie gegen meine eigene
mobilität die großmut in ihr eigenes
wesen integriert und wenn unter großboot
zitat aufopferung mit bewusstsein und
nacht gegriffen zitat ende verstanden
ist heißt dies das gefühl der liebe als
natürliche begriff lose hingabe an einem
anderen wird durch vernunft gewirkte
tugend komplettiert
eines stellt sich die vollkommen die
jährliche vereinigung von seiten des
mannes dar indem er die wünsche der frau
berücksichtigt erhält und farbe ihre
liebe in dem er seine eigene
zwecksetzung zugunsten der frau
modifiziert gibt auch er sich hin und
gewinnt sich in der liebe der frau als
willens subjekt zurück auch für den mann
bedeutet dieses verhältnis bereicherung
seiner selbst das menschliche herz
öffnet sich der liebe wie fichte wagt er
sich unbefangen in gegenden und im
gegenstände verlorenen liebe
im idealfall steigert sich die
verbindung beider partner so weit dass
die umtausch um die herzen und der wm
voll kommen wird das war ein zitat
zusammengenommen ergibt sich damit eine
komplexe struktur einheit jeder fahrt
verliert und findet sich nun anderen so
dass die vereinten teile sich auch
moralischer hinsicht zu einem ganzen
menschen ergänzen sie sind komplimente
toten aber nicht als solche sondern nur
vermittels der je verschiedene
bezugnahme des einen auf den anderen
oder seitdem stellt sich jedes
individuum durch und in diesem bezug in
moralischer hinsicht für sich selbst als
ganzer mensch ja indem es die nun
fehlende seite des anderen integriert
der moralische charakter der frau wird
vernünftig der des mannes natürlich denn
liebe und großmut verhalten sich wie
natur und vernunft ansicht von moralität
zueinander auf diese weise ist das die
lösung des problems der ihre theorie
erreicht die widersprüchlichkeit von
natur und vernunft im geschäftsleben der
frau ist in einer gemeinschaft produktiv
aufzulösen in der sich mann und frau als
liebender zugleich zusätzlich
qualifizierten fall und wesen bilden die
genannten aspekte von vereinigung der
teile des individuums und der
individuell als teile zu einem ganzen
lösen auch dem selbstzweck charakter der
ihr plausibel werden
sie ist die einzige gemeinschafts form
in der der einzelne mensch sich als
natürliches und vernünftiges wesen ohne
verlust seiner integrität ausleben kann
denn zitat die befriedigung des
geschlechtstriebs ist nur in der ehe
erlaubt außer ja aber bandscheibe
gänzliche wegwerfen ihre friedlichen
charakters weil meine trainer an diesen
verbrechen und benutzung einer
tierischen neigung
cetin in der ehe kann sich der mensch
gewesen realisieren indem er die ihm als
geschlechtlich bestimmtes individuum
beschränkenden einseitigkeiten
überwindet weil der mensch ist ähnlichen
verhältnis die gattung in der fülle des
begriffs afghanisten menschen jenseits
der begrenzenden geschlechts charaktere
aber auch im sinne der einheit mehrerer
individuen erfährt und realisiert ist es
nach dem sittenlehre von 98 licht in
diese verbindung einzutreten zitat die
unverheiratete person ist nur zur hälfte
zitat ende demnach ist die eher eine
vollkommene vereinigung zweier personen
beiderlei geschlechts die ihr eigener
zweck ist ein aha jetzt ihr der
menschwerdung in den genannten aspekten
lässt sich nicht denken
ge ist auch insofern eine ausgezeichnete
form von vereinigungen als die sie
bestimmungen momente ein dynamisches
verhältnis es sich ergeben und der natur
zur sittlichkeit erkennen lassen dieser
der ehe immer nur dynamik entspricht in
der geschichtlichen welt die durch die
ihre in gang gesetzte moralisierung der
menschheit wo es so schreiben erklärt
sichtete die wiederherstellung des
natürlichen verhältnisses der
geschlechter sei die einzige möglichkeit
das menschengeschlecht von natur aus zur
tugend zu führen es gebe keine sittliche
erziehung von diesem punkt aus
der sphäre der moralität findet mit
hinein die natürlichen vorgängen
zumindest analoger bildungsprozess stadt
die sittliche gemeinschaft der
geschlecht nicht differenten individuen
in der sich der mensch als gattung zu
bewusstsein kommt bildet die
mannigfaltigkeit von individuen zur
einheit eines menschlichen vernunft
ganzen
damit endet der darstellende tage gültig
kommen jetzt zum überlegungen im
anschluss an die feministische
auseinandersetzung mit diesem lehrstück
handelt es sich um eine befreiungstag in
dieser neuen die lehre oder um eine
ideologische legitimierung weiblicher
unmündigkeit und rechtlosigkeit im
kontext der geschichte des ihr rechts
stellt sich fichtes wir lehrer als
fortschritt dar fichte sprechende
erlösende wort so heißt es dass das
rational aufklärerische ihre verständnis
des absolutismus gebe zur folge die ehe
eine durch äußere zwänge begründete
vertragsgemeinschaft darstelle zu fall
bringen in dieser perspektive trägt
fichtes auffassung der ihr nicht nur der
ansicht rechnung dass das natürliche
sich nicht verrechtlichen lasst sie
ersetzt auch die auf kalter vernunft
beruhende der vertragsgemeinschaft etwa
in der form wie kann sie verliert hat
durch die innigkeit der liebes
gemeinschaft so eindrucksvoll fichte
sentimental der ihr als der zartesten
verbindung zwischen menschen für die
bürgerliche welt gewesen sein mag die
feministisch orientierte
auseinandersetzung mit diesem lehrstück
hat einen solchen glitzernden idealismus
wie man mit nietzsche sagen könnte zu
recht und zwar in form fundamentaler
weise widersprochen
die nüchtern das heißt mit den realen
verhältnissen
konnte kein zweifel daran lassen dass
diese idee ein stück patriarchaler
ideologie geschichte ist das dazu
beitragen konnte wie es berichte selbst
heißt die unbegrenzte sste unterwerfung
der frau unter dem willen des mannes in
ganz anderer weise noch zu fördern und
zu festigen und zu rechtfertigen als es
bei fichtel der fall war
wesentliche bestandteile der
bürgerlichen ideologie
einseitig von der frau mit weitgehender
rechtlosigkeit gepaarte liebe und jung
habe im vertrauen auf kompensationen des
landes zu fordern sind entrichtet er war
vorgezeichnet
im nüchternen blick auf die frauen
benachteiligende realität ist die
sicherung gleichen rechts auch edle er
als das notwendige korrektiv inzwischen
erfolgt die drohkulisse eines die würde
der frau gefährdeten natur triebs ist
ebenso in sich zusammen gefallen wie die
also galt für einseitige unterwerfung
und entrechtung
angebotenen verklärungen und überholung
der liebes gemeinschaft sich entzaubert
vielen dank